hallo mein name ist programm herzlich
willkommen heute zu einem neuen real
live video wir befinden uns heute auf
einem fußballplatz und zwar haben wir
schon bei ihr seht im hintergrund wir
haben ein tor und zwar machen leute
latten schießt hatten schießen alleine
wäre ein bisschen traurig und ich habe
in meinem leben noch einen freund und
das ist max hey ich bin lukas arbeit
nicht mehr deswegen haben uns gedacht
wir versammeln uns hier heute vor allem
tor und schießen aus 11 das war kein
elfmeter abmessen
dann legen wir das t shirt hin und ab
hier müssen wir quasi drauf schießen 105
schätze und leute weil natürlich eine
normale fußballfans zu mainstream ist
haben wir uns eine kinderschwimmen
brille gekauft ihre dabei jederzeit
fünfmal und der am ende weniger die
latte fliegt er das analysen schüttler
der am ende von den fünf schützen
weniger getroffen hat er bekommen eine
wasserpistole einfach überlegen
geschossen und die übrigens sind gerade
in die locker 30 grad deswegen stehen
wir hier irgendwie alle halbnackt wir
haben kameramann auch max schütt coming
home verletzten
nachdem max nervosität keine spur und
macht er ganz ganz schlecht ganz
schlecht daher ist ich hab immer noch
rückenschmerzen ich hab dazu gestern
schon wieder gemacht dass berlin ich
euch irgendwo hier warum so ein fußball
change mit dem ständigen rennen erstmal
wie schlecht es wissen ja was diese
brille in so einem scheiß gut dass diese
brillen so eine chance hast gekauft das
eigentlich kinderbrillen wir haben die
bis aufs äußerste angespannt
ich werde jetzt auf jeden fall treffen
sein vierter schluss meine damen und
herren wir haben immer noch weiter
überhaupt nicht getroffen
als ärgerlich alles aufgesetzte total
dumm schuss an die latte zu schießen
wenn ich das mache damit war das ist
dann schluss
irgendwelche worte das war meine letzte
chance freunde da wir jetzt beide von 5
stück eingezogen die mails mit dem kers
einfach fünf meter nach vorne machen
jetzt ko also jeder hat einen schuss und
wenn einer trifft einen anderen nicht
treffe ich ende hexenschuss wenn der
reingeht ist es vorbei
wegen maus einfach so dass keine
gewinnen fand die könnten treffen hat
aber wir wollen weil ich sag euch ich
war heute mein t shirt da auf dem boden
weiger
dass wir auf dem rasen ich könnt euren
rat beschreibt man jetzt alle die
kommentare ob ich das mag jetzt startet
jetzt 50,43
deutlich krieg jetzt ein super sommer
strand in die fresse gucken wie kommst
du klar da hinten kein scheiß
er wollte gerade in dieses tor schießen
als den pfosten vorbeigeschossen da
hinten raus und der hat gerade gegen
mich gewonnen
alles klar damit ist heute hier
versammelt um diese schießt wieder
komplett wir haben uns irgend so eine
app store gekaufte seht schon wenn man
die schon ordentlich freunde dann
beendet wenn es euch gefallen hat die
größten feiern
pakesch verlierer wenn euch das gefallen
hat so eine challenge dann lass die
bewertung da macht kanal ist irgendwo
verlinkt und sie sehen uns danke auch am
meisten
wir sehen uns beim nächsten